قبل وصولي ،
تم وضع برنامج العقوبات الرئيسي ، وأعتقد
أنه كان فعالًا للغاية فيما يتعلق بما تم
تصميمه من أجل
اعتقادك أنني كنت أعتزم إبقاء روسيا
تحرم روسيا من الموارد التي تحتاجها
لتنفيذ الحرب التي أرادتها
لذلك هذا المشروع الإمبراطوري
بالاستيلاء على أوكرانيا بسرعة ومن ثم التمكن
من فرض نفسها بشكل صحيح على نطاق أوسع ،
لكنها لم تجبر
الكرملين على تغيير سياساته لتغيير
سلوكه جيدًا ، أعتقد على الرغم من أنك
ترى فرقًا حقيقيًا ومعظم
هذا  يعود الفضل إلى الأوكرانيين ،
أعني أن شجاعتهم وإبداعهم في
ساحة المعركة كانا رائعين ،
لكنك رأيت الكرملين يواصل تغيير
ما قال إن أهدافه كانت صحيحة ،
فقد بدأ بغزو شامل
لأوكرانيا ومحاولة لأخذ  تحول رأس المال
إلى نوع من
التحسين التدريجي على الأرض التي
استولت عليها قبل الحرب والآن
يعيد تلك الأراضي مرة أخرى ، وبالتالي فهذه
تغييرات حقيقية في
السلوك الروسي  بالنسبة للعقوبات
جزئياً لتصدير الضوابط ، لا يمكنهم شراء
أنواع المدخلات التي يحتاجونها من أجل حقهم
العسكري
في العمل ، هل
تعتقد في النهاية أن نظام العقوبات الذي تفرضه
الولايات المتحدة على روسيا
والدول الأخرى سيفرضه أيضًا
الكرملين على الاستسلام أو إجباره على
التراجع في هذا أعتقد جيدًا أن
أهم شيء هو شجاعة
الأوكرانيين والالتزام الذي
يظهرونه في ساحة المعركة
ما قلناه كحكومة هو
أننا مع أوكرانيا من الآن وحتى
نهاية هذه الحرب حتى تنجح أوكرانيا
وهذا يعني دعم الاقتصاد
وهو أيضًا جزء مما نفعله هنا
للتأكد من أن أوكرانيا قادرة على
تصدير العملة ، فهذا يعني دعم
المبادرات الإنسانية
والجيش والعقوبات  قطعة من
ذلك ولكنها ليست سوى قطعة واحدة منه